e
e e
so good afternoon everyone um welcome to
legislative Administration can I ask
representative TIY to lead us in the
pledge
United
States for it stands one nation God
indivisible withy and justice for all
thank you very
much welcome to our last and maybe our
least consequential meeting of our
legislative term um for those of you who
have not been through this part of the
process um all we are doing today is
voting uh on a binary decision um to
recommend for future legislation or not
recommend for future legislation but
it's important to note that however the
vote turns out it does not preclude
anyone from filing legislation so in
that way it's
somewhat um ceremonial more than
anything else it's it's uh it's clearing
our docket of all of the bills that we
have um remaining which is two um we
have House Bill
157 and house uh resolution
25 um all we will be doing is uh seeking
a motion one or the other um of those
two options to recommend future
legislation or not recommend
we will have brief discussion um doesn't
have to be elaborate and uh and then we
will take a vote up or down however it
comes out it comes
out any
questions okay with that um I'll open
the executive session on House Bill 157
and
recognize our vice chair for
motion thank you Mr Mr chair um I would
move not recommended for future
legislation for House Bill 157
representative Sheen moves not
recommended for future legislation is
there a second who seconded seconded by
representative wall um would there be
any discussion representative would you
like to speak to your motion yes I would
thank you um during testimony our chief
operating officer said that the House
and Senate would be working on a joint
sexual harassment policy and procedures
we are told that this is in the final
stages and therefore no further
legislation along these lines would be
necessary thank you representative uh
further
discussion I will just add that uh The
Joint legislative uh yeah the joint
committee on legislative facilities met
this morning um and I did speak with uh
with Terry pa um and and Jim Cy our
house attorney and asked about uh the
progress and they are in the final
stages of putting together The Joint
House and Senate um policy uh they from
there they then um once they vote on it
it would then have to go through the
Ethics Committee um and so they're
they're making that final push
um I want to stress that this
bill um pretty much would have created
what what they have been working on so
there will be another piece of
legislation that's needed um that will
be coming back to this committee at some
point so but there is no uh I will be
voting and supporting the not
recommended for future legislation only
because this bill doesn't need to be
brought up again uh based on what they
are doing um with their their joint work
so uh with that um any future leg any
future conversation
discussion seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call a roll on House Bill 157
we are voting on not recommending future
legislation okay how does uh Vice chair
vote Yes Michael uh rep costable yes
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative Tyne yes
representative sers yes representative
wall yes
representative nting Wong yes
representative turot yes and
representative payer yes and how does
the chair
vote oh I'm sorry oh okay is is that
your last name commin okay Bill commin
oh so okay you're not a
sub
no sorry
okay and I guess and the chair yes
I would say unanimous unanimous I'll
just go back
um just like our committee typically
works we have a unanimous decision um so
with that uh we will be putting forth a
recommendation uh or no recommendation
but a recommendation for no
recommendation for House Bill 157 um but
that I'll close the executive session on
House Bill
157 and open up the
the um the discussion the executive
session on house resolution 25 and
recognize our vice chair um for a
motion thank you Mr chair I would move
not recommended for future legislation
for house resolution 25 it's hard not to
say house bill isn't it um so um we have
a motion of not recommended is there a
second seconded by represent pres ative
wall um open for
discussion representative cers thank you
Mr chair even though we may vote to not
recommend uh some form or fashion of
this bill probably should go forward
next year or the year after the the
whole intent of the resolution was to
tighten up and confirm our voting for
absentee ballots uh for one point and
there was a second part to it I can't
recall exactly what it was but we were
trying to tighten up or the at least the
group behind the bill was trying to
tighten up the the voting laws as far as
what goes on in so we just don't have
every option or every means of saying
you know I broke a fingernail I'm not I
need an absentee ballot so we were just
trying to say the Constitution says this
let's live by the Constitution and just
because it's not in the Constitution
doesn't mean we should should be doing
it that's all thanks thank you
representative um your fingernails
notwithstanding um we are strictly
deciding whe not on and I'm glad you
brought that up because we are not
basing our vote today on the merits or
demerits of of the Bill of the
legislation itself um we are or the
content of it we're strictly saying um
either we're putting this forward um
that there's something there that we
need to um look at but and it does not I
I need to emphasize it does not preclude
anyone from putting any other
legislation in or not uh later on so um
appreciate your your input um
representative uh do you have something
that I see writing so I'm assuming that
there's something else you would like to
add to that so we we saw a Supreme Court
decision very closely related to hr25
and the court wasn't particularly moved
by the arguments and the court sent the
case back to a lower court but just only
on the equal protection issues of that
case um thank you representative um that
is true there is uh there the reason
that we did set this aside was for um
for purposes of reviewing or or keeping
a close eye on the court case um um and
and because that court case hasn't been
fully completed it may be very well that
they're that if this bill is filed again
that we may hold on to it again just to
see what the lower court does on that
one remaining issue of equal protection
but um but as it stands now um there
would seem to be very little reason for
the bill in its present form and again
this is a house resolution which um
which almost um for some of us doomed it
from the start because that it only is a
statement for the house it doesn't go to
the Senate doesn't do anything else so
um I I see no reason for a house
resolution to come back to us with this
content um with that any further
discussion seeing none um I will ask the
clerk to call the rooll on house
resolution 25 and again we'll be voting
on not recommended for future
legislation okay on the vote uh hr25 no
no
recommendation um how does the vice
chair vote Yes representative costable
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson representative tyy yes
representative sers yes representative
wall yes representative nutting longam
yes representative turot yes
representative conin
yes representative payer
yes sorry uh all right that is oh and
the chair
sorry had to happen the last
time um I will vote Yes
okay that is unanimous we have our final
vote how symbolic that our final vote is
also unanimous um that pretty much
concludes so I'll close the session on
house resolution 25 and that clears up
our entire docket of bills for the year
um I just want to thank everybody for
your assistance and coming here early
and getting us out of here early and off
to the festivities um it's been um a
great pleasure for me to be the chair of
your committee thank you very much um I
hope to see you all
shortly rep yes representative thank you
Mr chairman and I want to thank this
committee for being a really great group
of people we've all worked together
really really well and it's almost like
family um and I just want to say it's
been an honor having Greg and
Vanessa I too would be remiss to not
thank um our Clerk who is retiring today
um from from the legislature uh so um
it's been great we've uh worked together
for quite a few years um thank you very
much and I also like to thank our vice
chair who has uh kept us on the straight
and narrow more than you know
um okay as much as you know um thank you
again uh to both of you thanks thank you
else we're good
adjourn have a great good luck in
everyone
selection for